[موسيقى
] رجل سوريا المفقود هو جهة الاتصال التي
بدأت في تطويرها في
بداية العام الذي كنت أعمل فيه في الأردن
ولبنان بشكل أساسي من اللاجئين الذين
عبروا الحدود في 2012-2013 ، لذا فقد
استقروا على سونيك في البلدان
التي  لقد لاحظت أن
الرجال كانوا يكافحون كثيرًا لذا
أردت أن أعرف سبب ذلك
ويبدو أن لديهم مشاكل أكبر في
الاندماج من النساء والأطفال
الذين تراهم في الضغط وعدم القدرة
على النهوض من السرير  وهذا شيء
أردت توثيقه وعرضه لأنني
أعتقد أنه شيء ليس فقط في هذه
البلدان هو النوع الأول من البلدان التي
تستقبل الأشخاص ولكن أيضًا على طول الطريق ،
يحاول أحد الأجزاء الكبيرة من ذلك العثور على هدف مرة أخرى ومحاولة
لإعادة البناء وما
مروا به في السابق
ومغادرة البلاد ، لكنك تعلم في الواقع
تعطيل ما يحتاجون إليه للاستمرار في
حاجتهم إلى دعم المنظمات غير الحكومية عند وصولهم
إلى البلدان و
المنظمات المستعصية بقدر ما يحتاجون إليها ،
إنها أيضًا مدمرة لهم
وكذلك الرجال معتادون على الخروج
والعمل لساعات طويلة ، ويبدو سياق
الحصول على الصدقات أمرًا
مخجلًا لكثير من هؤلاء الرجال
تقريبًا كل شخص تحدثت معه
أقارب فقدوا أطرافهم
عندما تخرج من هذا الموقف ، فإن أول
شيء ستشعر به هو الحاجة إلى
إعادة البناء والمضي قدمًا في أكبر
أمنياتي للأشخاص الذين قضيت وقتًا معهم
حتى يتمكنوا من ذلك.  الخروج
من حالة عدم الثبات في
كل شخص تحدثت إليه تقريبًا كعامل ذي قيمة
لديه ما يقدمه إذا كان من
الممكن السماح لهم بفعل ما يريدون
القيام به ، فسيكونون أفضل حالًا من الناحية
النفسية وسيستفيد المجتمع
أيضًا كما أعتقد
سيؤدي ذلك إلى إضفاء الطابع الإنساني على الناس ، والخطوة الأولى
هي رؤية وجوه الناس وإدراكها
في صورة أناس حقيقيين ، إما الآباء ، والأزواج ،
والأبناء.
usic]